well for 20 years my wife argues more
than 20 years but I have trouble
remembering more than 20 years for 20
years at least this story about a cook
and his pre teenage son has been in my
mind surprisingly I knew quite a lot
about this story as long as 20 years ago
but not enough to really get started I I
began and finished several novels that
had been in my mind not nearly as long
because in their cases the last
sentences came to me and as you probably
know I I never begin a novel until I've
written that last sentence in in 12
novels not even the punctuation in those
last sentences has changed and and once
I get that last sentence I can manage to
make a kind of roadmap of the story find
my way back to where I think the book
should begin that's just been my process
and and continues to be my process but
in this books case there was something
missing from what I knew and I couldn't
for the longest time I couldn't get that
that ending clearly in mind although I
knew a lot about the story I knew these
two men were fugitives I knew they would
be on the run for 50 years I knew that
the story began in a kind of frontier
justice sort of place one law a bad cop
I knew it was close to the Canadian
border
and most of all I knew why the cook had
this 12 year old boy because by the end
of the novel I knew that kid would have
become a writer
and it would turn out that he was
actually writing the very story we've
been reading that may seem like a lot to
know to not get started but I I saw that
there were things that had been kept
from this boy that he didn't
and I didn't know what those things were
well there are certain sentences along
the way that seem pivotal or fragments
of sentences there are certain phrases
that I see as being of use somewhere in
the story
sometimes actual chapter titles
sometimes locations it's not a very
elaborate road map it's really a bunch
of post-it notes that are either on the
wall in front of me or on the desktop
where I work so that I can put my finger
on any one of those signposts when I you
know feel the need to it's it's
basically the skeleton of the story it's
the action of the novel when did the
characters meet do their paths cross
again do they live do they die if they
die when where how those kinds of things